if you put your finger in your ear and
scratch it sounds just like Batman
Saudi Arabia imports camels from
Australia a shark is half as likely to
kill you as a vending machine
Oxford University is older than the
Aztec empire France was still executing
people with the guillotine when the
first Star Wars film came out Betty
White is actually older than sliced
bread a strawberry is not a berry but
bananas avocados and watermelons are
mammoths were extinct 1,000 years after
the Egyptians finished building the
Great Pyramid there are more fake
flamingos in the world than real
flamingos the last time the Chicago Cubs
won the World Series the Ottoman
Empire's still existed humans share 50%
of their DNA with bananas honey never
spoils you can eat 30 2000 year old
honey on Saturn and Jupiter it rains
diamonds
one in every 5,000 babies is born
without an anus and has to have one
created manually in the hospital
speaking of anuses turtles can breathe
out affairs
and finally dog food lid backwards dildo
oh God